i'm clark wolfe with dc generic
[Applause]
good to see you gal how are you clark hi
clark
hi pedro how are you hi kristin how are
you
so hi patty um it's so great to see you
so
i wanted to start by asking things are
a little different than late spring
2017 when the first movie came out
um and so i wanted to ask you if
it was if this journey playing this
character again playing diana again did
it feel at all different for you
um you know or was it kind of just
slipping back into
what you had established in the first
film um it was both
it was both um you know the one wonder
woman family is like my
it's like my second home so coming back
and shooting with the same crew
and patty and the cast it just felt like
coming back home again
on the other hand um i was really
looking like you know if
on the first movie we got to witness the
born
of wonder woman diana prince becoming
wonder woman
i was really eager and passionate about
telling the story of wonder woman okay
now she's in her full powers she
understands because she understands the
complexities of humankind
now i want to explore her in a deeper
deeper level
and that's what we wanted to do with
this movie so i wanted to start by
asking uh so wonder woman to me as a
you know comics nerd dc fan movie fan
etc
is is not only a character um that
represents you know female
empowerment but also relationships
between
women and i was really struck by how the
relationship between diana and barbara
plays out in in wonder woman 84. so i
was wondering if you could talk a little
bit about
why it was important or why if you felt
it was important to
get that relationship right absolutely i
love this question it's such an
interesting one
so yeah i think the for for me the thing
about it is so often uh
we you we have all of these complex
different kinds of care
relationships particularly growing up
and the relationship between barbara and
diana reminds me a lot of relationships
i had when i was young
with different friends when you're all
kind of competitive in junior high
but yet you're friends and so it was
really fun to kind of draw upon that to
kind of make this very
organic story that where a real
friendship
evolves into something that could drive
both of these people in such different
directions
so i i loved it and also it's great
working with other women because you
know exactly the shorthand you're
talking about
what was interesting was i did get
questions from some
men sometimes where they were saying
shouldn't barbara be meaner or shouldn't
she be this or what's motivating her
and i was saying that's so interesting
we i can tell exactly what's motivating
her
trust me you know and it's it's
interesting that other women get it
completely as well
wow that's a good question um because we
really did want to get it right
i mean where barbara goes
from where you meet her is so uh
is so important because in in the very
beginning diana is like very
isolated and she's very lonely and she's
not
really a part of society and barbara is
the same but
for different reasons a little more um
diana probably gets invited to parties
where barbara probably doesn't
um so i think that commonality really
um brings them together and
you have to see it was really important
for all three of us
that that you you have to see this thing
in barbara that diana's like
uh gravit that she gravitates towards
and i think what it's
a little more clear what someone would
want to be like diamond friends
so yeah they wanted to show like a real
friendship there and it also
makes the the arc
of like becoming the villain so much
more interesting and like the conflict
within diana of how she feels about her
it just makes it just takes it to like
another
level uh first of all we don't get to
witness many times in the superhero
films you know a dynamic between two
women
and what was interesting here was that
they
both saw something in each other
that they wanna had um so that was super
interesting for me and i think that it
was also refreshing to see wonder woman
in you know kind of um engaging
with someone finally after being alone
for 60 something years
finally she's engaging she wants to be
close to someone new
and this someone is cheetah is barbara
um and it was delightful and it was
delightful to play with uh with kristen
and i think she's done a magnificent
work uh with her character talk to me
about maxwell lord how would you say
that he uh stacks up in the
bigger dc rogues gallery
i'm so in love with the experience of
playing max lord
in wonder woman 1984 that i often forget
what the context is and what his history
is with the comics and everything like
that
because what um what what what patty has
created with this movie is is so
um unique and also
um in service of uh you know
the the the dc universe and and
max's a place in it and um
all i can really say is that it's it's
it's two things you know
it it's it's it's um
it's a very kind of nostalgic and
earlier version
uh an earlier understanding of of of
this character
and um and yet also very directly
related to
um an era that we're capturing in this
movie and
and an era that we're using to tell a
very specific story and
to express a very specific danger so
speaking of you know the origins of
their relationship uh dc
universe infinite has this amazing
collection
of dc comics for fans to access were
there any specific
runs or stories that inspired you for
this film
no there were all of them i mean
obviously kingdom come
like with the incredible armor and
george perez
ends up being all over the place you
know in in all of the version
of the wonder woman we brought to life
but there what it really was an amalgam
of so many
you know it's so many little details
because things from max lord come from
one place and things from barbara
minerva come from another place and i
i was honestly so great to write it with
jeff johns because jeff
is like a warehouse of of information
about everything and so
we're able to then do little easter eggs
all over the place of even things i
haven't read so it's
it was you know it was really fun to
pull so much from so many places and i
wrote it with and dave callahan too i'm
just saying it was fun to write with
somebody who's an expert but the three
of us wrote it together and
loved it um in the very beginning i mean
i was
aware of cheetah but i i didn't know
there were
like a handful of different versions of
her and who she was and how she meets
diana and how she ends up and how she
gets her powers there's like a few
different um there were like a few
different ways to go and when i talked
to patty in the very beginning i didn't
know
even like physically what she would look
like because there's so many different
versions of her
so ultimately i just i
took what was written and tried to
figure out
who she was there and then patty just
really
guided me through um the rest of it i
i knew signing on to this project that
that the fans are a really big part of
the movie
and i i was nervous and i it was i was
you know i wanted them to like it
and i wanted to do my i mean just to be
totally honest like i
i i know people were surprised when when
i was
cast and patty was just like
had this vision from even obviously for
a while before i was even involved and i
just wanted to trust that
and like do the best job that i could
and i mean i hope i hope the fans like
it
um and and the cheetah that we
ended up with really was like a
combination of just
patty and i talking about where she
wanted to go and where she started from
and we wanted audiences to to feel like
they related to her in the beginning
yes well to that point uh you know
so this character we've seen him in a
handful of animated movies and comic
books and on television however
you know the way that you portray him i
feel like he
is so humanized and yet
he is larger than life it's a very like
really interesting balance can you talk
to me a little bit about
you know your work in terms of try
making sure to to humanize him and to
make him
feel like a person who has a back story
and it's
not just you know this simple black and
white like wicked witch of the west
type of thing what you're asking me
the only way to answer it is that that
is a
patty jenkins experience
and i having been familiar with her work
and having
seen the kinds of um
wholeness the kind of wholeness that
comes with a character
in her in her in her films and in her
television work
um i sort of understood my initial
instinct when i saw what was on the page
was that oh i
i i understand i understand this person
um which is kind of frightening to admit
to be honest
with you and so
it was simply a matter of achieving them
and that
i couldn't come close to doing without
her
and it was constant permission to
to to risk more and more and to lean
more and more into what we were
discovering about this character
um in his broadness in his
um uh in his darkness in his
you know everything that you've seen and
and and just to go there and go there
and go
there and go there and that was pat that
is
patty i am her instrument i know that
it's
those kind of you know sycophantic
but it it it's really really amazing to
be able to
say this and mean it so completely
absolutely well it's speaking of maxwell
lord i had the
pleasure to speak with pedro yesterday
and he was of course so effusive about
working with you and you
empowering him to just go for it
um and i wanted to ask about you know
the idea that maxwell lord as he's
presented in this movie
especially in the 1980s could have
seemed like a caricature
but he does have like a very human
element while also being
very big uh which is great so can you
talk to me about like developing that
character
and and you know handling that character
yeah it's one of the things that i live
for in filmmaking i love
bigness and i love big emotions but
filling them
in with details that ground them is the
fun of the sport
you know even when i made monster it was
kind of the thrill of like
sinking into a story and really trying
to understand what that would feel like
to go through
and and give empathy to it and then same
thing with wonder woman
same thing with max lord who's your
villain i love
kind of trying to to track all of those
things with human
dynamics that we all understand so yeah
it was such a brave performance of
pedro's because you got to be
out there there's no safety net he'd
never
done anything like it before and but he
also brought so much humanity to it i'm
so
so happy he's getting celebrated the way
he is and kristen too
yeah absolutely well patty thank you so
much for chatting it was lovely to see
you and congratulations on the movie
great to see you thank you take care
this is a lot of fun
and uh happy holidays thank you happy
holidays stay safe
well thank you so much kristen excellent
work in the movie it's really great and
you're wonderful and i think the fans
are going to be very happy
okay okay well thank you so much gail
happy hanukkah
happy hanukkah thank you so much